Caretakers take care of things.
There are many kinds of caretakers.
This gardener is a caretaker.
He takes care of gardens.
This road worker is a caretaker.
She takes care of the roads.
This babysitter is a caretaker.
She takes care of babies.
This dentist is a caretaker.
He takes care of teeth.
This vet is a caretaker.
He takes care of animals.
This doctor is a caretaker.
She takes care of people.
These firefighters and police officers are caretakers.
They take care of people, too.
Who is he?
He is a dentist. He takes care of our teeth.
Are they police officers?
Yes, they take care of people.
Who is she?
She is a vet. She takes care of sick animals.